so how did this opportunity come about
to be on Celebrity Big Brother well you
know they called me and asked me if I
wanted to do the show and I said
absolutely this is amazing so I'm
excited about about the opportunity and
I know it's gonna be a little weird but
I'm looking forward to it and why did
you say yes absolutely
well you know I I love the show I have
done a show like this before I did
Celebrity Apprentice I was on the second
season and I kind of learned I think a
little bit from some of my mistakes that
I made on that show and I've often sort
of said to myself you know if I was ever
do you know a competition show like this
again a reality show like that again I
would probably do things differently and
I'm looking for but I just you know
honestly it's it's not so much to do
with that it's I just I do I do
find it really interesting just the
whole concept of being completely off
the grid you know I'm I'm a person like
all of us who's addicted to my cell
phone I'm stuck on that thing on my
comedy tour I'm always posting to my
Instagram and my Twitter and interacting
on social media and it can kind of
become overwhelming and you can
constantly be stuck on your phone and to
be away from that for a month
potentially a month is something that I
think is just gonna be interesting for
me just sort of on an interesting social
experiment I think so and I think I can
win too
I do think I can win so I wouldn't I
wouldn't be playing if I wasn't playing
to win I as a stand-up comedian I
interact with a lot of people I am used
to being living out of a suitcase I'm
used to living out of a suitcase I'm
travelling around the world now in a
world tour I'm just I'm literally going
in the last few years of performed in
every city in the US and Israel and in
England and going my first Asian tour
this year I'm going to be in Hong Kong
Tokyo all over the world so it's you
know I spend a good part of my year
living out of a suitcase and I'm away
from home a lot
I think that mentally prepares me for
the challenge of being away from my
friends and family on the show and
winning Brit Big Brother and winning Big
Brother and what do you think you
learned from Celebrity Apprentice that
you will take to the Big Brother house
what to do what not to do well you know
I'm known for doing some pretty
outrageous comedy my show at MTV was
over-the-top some of my movies are just
really crazy and wacky and I always like
to bring that persona I always like to
bring that persona to my shows that I
appear on and on that was no exception
when I was on the Celebrity Apprentice I
definitely tried to kind of stir up a
little bit of controversy with some of
the interactions I was having with the
other people I was trying to make it a
little crazy a little little wacky and I
don't think that necessarily ingratiated
me to the other members of the of the
show and so you know that's always
that's that's always been a character
really like Lego I think you know my
show on MTV was so crazy some of my
films are just so over the top
Freddy got fingered was just a
completely insane movie that I made and
and so I think sometimes people may have
the impression that that's me and that's
not really Who I am I'm actually a
little bit more of a down-to-earth
person I think a little bit more normal
than you would maybe expect and so I'm
gonna try to be myself on this show and
when I was on on the sleppy apprentice
house maybe trying to be funny and doing
some things that maybe weren't
necessarily best for my gameplay so so I
think that that's gonna be my strategy
here I'm gonna go in and and maybe lay a
little low at the top of the game maybe
try not to get try to fly a little under
the radar off the top get to know some
of the other housemates and and see how
that goes and you said you're used to
traveling all over the world but now
you're going to be confined to a house
with other celebrities so how do you
feel about that well I'm curious too I'm
curious to find out who I might know in
there I have interviewed a lot of people
over the years I
and talk shows and I've interviewed so
many people and I'm pretty sure I may
know some people in there I don't know
who they're gonna be but so I don't know
if that might actually not help me you
know I sometimes if you know people on
Big Brother it can be a disadvantage
because it makes you potentially have an
alliance that an unintentional alliance
that people might be a little bit
threatened by so but living with a bunch
of other celebrities I don't know I
think it's going to be weird I'm not
exactly I can't say that that's gonna be
I like weird stuff I'm a weird guy
I do like weird stuff and I think the
weirdness of it will be interesting and
but it's definitely you know I'm also
somebody that likes my privacy I like to
be able to you know have some alone time
and it's gonna be strange being
constantly watched I have feeling it
could be a little bit uncomfortable but
I guess that's what makes the show cool
is there any celebrity that you're
hoping is in the house in any celebrity
that you're like crap if they're in the
house all right
I'm screwed you know there's nobody I'm
worried about I get along with everybody
I mean I try to I try to be positive and
like I said I've interviewed a lot of
people over the years and I've gotten
good at you know talking to people and
and so I'm not so worried about anyone
in particular and even if there's
somebody who's outrageous or is an
instigator that to me is entertaining so
I'm gonna feel like I'm watching Big
Brother from inside the show so I think
that'll be really cool anybody that
would like in there again it's it's it's
it's it's a conflicting thing because
you know if some of my friends are in
there or people that I know or people
that I've met that could be detrimental
to my game so I'm just kind of not
hoping for anything either way and I'm
just going to go in and go with the flow
and and and
and and and basically you know work with
what I'm given what's your biggest fear
going into the house well I mean not
winning not winning is my biggest fear I
mean I obviously I'm aware that it's
it's a big deal to win it's not easy to
win I mean there's there's a lot of
smart people in there and everybody's
competing for the same thing and the
odds of winning are probably low right
but that I'm a competitive person I
think the idea of getting voted off
could be a little bit you know of a
bummer
right it could be a little uncomfortable
and I'm not you know III don't really
want it I don't really want that to
happen I'd like to win so you know I'm a
little bit sort of I'm a little bit
freaked out about the idea of like
showering and using the bathroom with
cameras that just seems a little weird
to me understandably I'm not you know
but I'm not I'm not totally freaked out
by that some of the contests look fun
I've been a lot of sort of you know like
I said my show was pretty over-the-top
I'm pretty comfortable getting covered
in slime or I'm covered in goo or liquid
or water or getting in strange
situations with with my comedy so I'm
not really uncomfortable about the
competitions I think those will be fun I
think I love an advantage and some of
those things
what about slop how are you gonna handle
the food eating slop well that does not
look that does not look does not look
tasty but again I mean that's I think I
can handle it I can handle the slop mmm
would be my first choice of meal but I
can handle it and you know on regular
Big Brother when if the celebrity does
or says anything you know they just go
back to their regular lives afterwards
but if you guys do or say anything
you're still a celebrity so how worried
are you about everybody watching you
guys 24/7 and anything you do or say you
know you're a celebrity afterwards you
know I built a television Stu
in my living room a few years ago I did
my I did an independent online talk show
from my house and I think that puts me
in a sort of slight position of not
maybe not necessarily an advantage but I
have experienced a little bit of that
the idea of having cameras in my house
they weren't streaming 24 hours deck
it's a lot different but you know I
think I'm kind of I've done a lot of you
know I you know I'm it's let me think
about my answer for that I mean there's
no question is gonna be crazy there's no
question this is going to be completely
crazy and weird and uncomfortable and
but that's what makes it fun
and and I'm down for the challenge love
it and a few stars in season one a
Celebrity Big Brother thought this was
too much and ended up quitting is there
anything that could make you quit I
don't think so I don't think so I don't
think there's anything that could make
me quit cut to me in tears and three
days from now and banging on a door and
also a big thing on Big Brother our show
manses how willing are you to get in a
show man so you know there's a lot of
pretty ladies in that house I'm in a
very happy relationship hi Jessica love
you
there's no showmance happening with me
and I also think that that is probably
really detrimental to your game and I'd
be curious if that even happened on
Celebrity Big Brother I don't think it's
this I don't think that's gonna be
something that happens on Celebrity Big
Brother I could be wrong won't be with
me though and did you reach out to
anyone from the first season for any
advice you know we were told we were
allowed to do that so I spoke to my
friend mark McGrath and you know he told
me how the experience was and
and but you know for the most part I've
just been been studying the game really
just studying the studying the show been
watching episodes of the show on CBS
comm and and enjoying that and coming up
with my own strategy so and a lot of
people use this show or Dancing with the
Stars as an opportunity to help further
their career or get something out of
this what do you hope to get out of
Celebrity Big Brother well I'm on a
world tour right now I'm doing stand-up
comedy
full time I'm traveling all around the
country I love doing stand-up I started
doing stand-up when I was 16 years old
and I'm 47 now so I've been doing
stand-up over 30 years but 10 years ago
I really started touring again
I've got incredible fans all around the
country who many of who grew up watching
MTV watching my show and I love going
around the country and performing so
this is really kind of a cool thing to
sort of expose myself to a new audience
of big brothers got a great fan base and
I want people to come see me on the road
I love doing stand-up Elect making
people laugh I like performing so so
that's really really an exciting thing
about Big Brother is it there is such a
huge hardcore fanbase of Big Brother
fans and a lot of them were watching my
show on MTV you know I think a lot of
people you know if people who aren't
super fans of mine maybe haven't been
paying attention to what I've been doing
it'll be good to be able to reconnect
with with some people who maybe watch my
show and MTV or grew up watching my
movies like road trip or Charlie's
Angels or Freddy got fingered you know
I've I've got a lot of great fans out
there who maybe haven't gotten to see me
in a few years so I'm excited to
reconnect with everybody why do you
think you have what it takes to win
Celebrity Big Brother well I think I
think that you know I've like I said
I've
I I think I have a little bit of an
element of surprise I think people make
people who are in the house may have one
expectation of Who I am as a person and
really I'm probably the opposite of that
I've spent a lot of time on camera over
the years my web shows and I'm
comfortable doing outrageous and
ridiculous things which Big Brother has
a lot about rages and ridiculous things
and you know I I do think I have I have
I don't think it's an impossible thing
to win I think I could win this game and
if you win you win some money so what
would you do with that prize oh I don't
know I haven't really haven't really
thought about it that's it's not the
motivation though for me to do the show
I I mean it's it is nice to to win I
really I just I really want to win just
I'm a competitive person I just I'd like
to win because I'm a competitive person
and I'd like to be Celebrity Big Brother
champion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]